we've got to do our our weekly probably
every three days segment on Jada pinket
Smith I don't know why I'm really I'm
really into their I don't know I know
I'm not a big pop culture guy I can't
tell you the last time I saw Will Smith
movie I certainly have I don't think
I've ever seen a Jada Smith movie or TV
show I think she's an actress but their
family Dynamic is illustrative of so
much of the breakdown of the American
family and so you remember she came out
and said she was cheating on her husband
on that show and he had to sit there
like a poor cockled and just bury his
anger inside him and then they went to
the Oscars together and he got up on
stage and smacked Chris Rock in the face
for some reason and then they announced
recently that they've been separated for
years since 2016 now Jada Smith can't
keep her mouth shut she's promoting A
Memoir of course she goes on the Today's
Show she says that she and her husband
are trying to reconcile if you find
another great love or If Will finds
another great love there's no finding
another great love and I think that's
the point it's like we are in a place
now that we are in a deep healing space
and we are really concentrating on
healing the relationship between us so
it may not be the divorce on paper
anymore there's no divorce on paper I
mean not on paper there might not be a
divorce in theory anymore yeah no we
really have been working hard oh see
well I didn't know on let's trying to
well wa I totally missed that on the
whole that's the whole thing so wait so
wait just so I'm 100% clear you were
divorced not on paper but now we might
be a point where we're back together we
are working very hard at bringing our
relation yes bringing our relationship
together back to a marriage again back
to a life
partnership
yes okay I I think this is a good
thing I
think there are a lot of people who when
Jada Smith said I cheated on my husband
or when he went up and smacked Chris
Rock or any of the other just terrible
things that have happened in their
marriage who said man he's got to leave
her because she seems crazy and she does
seem crazy but I don't think that they
should get divorced I might be the one
man in America I'm one of three people
in America it's me Will Smith and Jada
pinket Smith who don't think that Will
and Jada should get divorced I oppose
divorce in in all circumstances I don't
think it's even really possibility CU I
think what God has joined no man really
ultimately can separate so if they're
going to say hey we've got this horrible
marriage it's a horri it's it's a it's
really hard but we are going to try to
keep it together we're going to try to
work on it and bring it back together I
think that's a good thing now she's
using all this weird New Age liberal
hippie language we're working on mending
a life
partnership and we're doing the work of
the healing and that's not going to help
them
all that new Agy hippie BS is never
going to help them that's never helped
anybody ever in history the kind of
language that's going to help them is
going to be the old sturdy language of
marriage which is an old sturdy
institution that was not con constructed
by human
beings it it exists from the very
beginning of human beings because human
beings are the political and social
creature and a coupling creature we are
meant one for the other we are
complimentary men and women okay and the
marriage is a symbol of the relationship
between Christ and his church when when
Christ is speaking about divorce and and
he's hearing from all the scribes and
the Pharisees and all these legalists
and they're saying no you you can have a
divorce right and he says no no Moses
gave you a license to divorce because of
the hardness of your hearts but from the
beginning it was not so from the
beginning Jada Smith and Will Smith
for all of their faults and all of their
errors of thinking they've got this
point more correct than the modern
culture right now go to balance ofn
nature.com use promo code noes living a
healthy lifestyle is not easy especially
when you're always on the go you need
simple manageable routines to ensure you
get the proper nutrition each day which
is why I'm a huge fan of balance of
nature balance of nature fruits and
veggies are a great way to make sure you
are getting essential nutritional
ingredients every day balance of nature
uses an advanced cold vacuum process
that encapsulates fruits and vegetables
into Whole Food supplements without
sacrificing their natural antioxidants
the capsules are completely void of
additives fillers extracts synthetics
pesticides or added sugar the only thing
in balance of nature is fruit and veggie
capsules are well fruits and veggies
there's never been an easier way to make
sure you are getting your daily dose of
fruits and vegetables go to
balanceofnature.com use promocode NES
for 35% off your first order as a
preferred customer that is balanceof
nature.com promocodes for 35% off your
first first preferred order right now do
not wait you owe it to your body you owe
it to your Society you owe it to Nature
balanceof nature.com promo code nolles
is a teacher who's just G viral for uh
telling white people to stop encouraging
their daughters to be mothers this is a
special PSA for anyone who's raising a
white daughter please stop gassing your
white daughters up to be
mothers stop telling them that it is
their Destiny and their Birthright to
one day be a mother and they will one
day be a
parent but they want to quol but stop
making them feel like that's their
Birthright because they often grow up
feeling entitled to children and if they
can't have their own children they will
be entitled to take someone else's child
regardless of Ethics or morals they feel
obligated is the responsibility ility to
make their family
complete men started this men started
telling women that it is their Destiny
and their Birthright to be mothers and
that's the only Niche they have in life
Deni educ stop it stop okay so this guy
is giving his monologue here in front of
the gay BLM flag so it's not just the
regular gay flag it's like the super
duper extremist terrorist BLM flag
or gay flag rather nblm flag and flag
it's got it's just all mushed up into
one and kind of looks like a Palestinian
flag too actually because it's got the
little triangle coming in on that
anyway you know that this guy is coming
from a far-left position but what's
amazing is he hits two seemingly
unrelated far-left points here the first
one is women aren't supposed to be
mothers no no there's no there's no
purpose to life there's no there are no
things that we are called to do by
virtue of our sex and by virtue of our
humanity and being made in the image and
likeness of God and having a charge to
be fruitful and multiply no no no that's
not the point of life is just do
whatever you
want which is also implied by the flag
behind him but but you can't quite get
why why is it that he's telling white
women not to want to be
mothers oh
because they sometimes then if they
cannot have biological children adopt
non-white
babies what this guy said saying is that
he would
rather non-white children be orphans
than be raised by white people that's
how much that guy hates white people
that he would rather Black and Hispanic
and Asian and whatever other kind of
children be orphans raised in an
orphanage be killed through abortion
perhaps be left on the streets then have
to be raised by white people and he says
it's just Terri the entitlement of these
white people what entitle
to take an orphan into their homes and
raise them and invest money and time and
care and their lives into these kids
yeah that compassion that charity that's
really evil and selfish as
always leftism is not just a little bit
perverted it's a total inversion of
reality and it's an inversion we see
this especially of Christian
Faith Christian says there is neither
Jew nor Greek nor slave nor free nor man
nor woman but all are one in Christ
Jesus this guy says it is a fate worse
than death for a black person to be
raised by a white
family the Christian faith says be
selfless give of yourself just take take
in the orphan okay the Liberals say no
it it would be that's actually selfish
somehow how does someone who holds those
views who's come to that ution how do
they get through their day their view of
reality is so totally skewed it's so off
how do they manag to not just spend
their day walking into walls and falling
into ditches boy what a great clip that
was
now make
sure that you ring that Bell subscribe
to the Michael NS YouTube channel we'll
see you next time